welcome to session five of dr sather's
philosophy forum on another
uh saturday in in april i have uh
another guest on
uh my friend and colleague morris stern
who
is going to talk quite a bit about kant
we might spill over into some other
areas as well and i'd like to mention
for those who are either
watching or
who are seeing the
video of this that morris is going to be
appearing on the punk rock philosopher's
show something that that he and i have
both been collaborating with
he's going to be on it hopefully two
saturdays
the 26th of april and
the third of may talking some more about
about kant and the punk rock philosopher
show is run by
um
another guy who who mixes together a lot
of music
some philosophical reflections he he
started bringing in people who are
experts on on particular subjects texts
thinkers
and so
this is a sort of natural spin-off
morris by the way is not you know
confined to
just kant he his his expertise spills
over into a lot of different areas as
i've discovered through through
conversations with him
so morris is going to be doing he's
going to be the principal in this he's
going to be answering you know the the
bulk of the the questions if there's
anything left to tidy up after that all
all come in i'll be the mc more or less
we already have some questions if you
want to
to uh give us questions you can you can
use the the question and answer
application um
but now i'm going to turn it over to
morris and he's going to talk
uh he's going to tell us some basic
things about [ __ ] and then some of the
things that really got him
interested in kant and probably some
other things as well
all right so i guess i'll say a few
things about how i got into con
and i guess in addition to that um
looking at the questions here i see that
the questions are quite piecemeal
they're asking about this and that
um i think it may be helpful if i gave a
kind of a synoptic uh idea of what kant
is all about
where the smaller well where the details
fit in
so
maybe a good place to start is something
like
the first few lines of the critique of
fear reason where can't ask or rather
starts with a question or starts with an
issue i should say and the issue is this
reason asks itself questions that it
itself cannot answer
now
that tells us
that
um well
the life of the mind is what is
interesting about khan
um we are as rational beings are not
we're not just simply copying what there
is in the world we're not just simply uh
forming copies of
perceptions in our minds
but our mind far outstrips what we
happen to perceive in the world and one
way
we are conscious of that is that we ask
questions that
overshoot what we perceive questions
like
where does the universe come from where
is the universe ultimately going
questions about god for example so these
are the questions that obviously go way
beyond what we can conceive
and of course the knee-jerk reaction is
to say that what we know
is
limited
by what we perceive only and
goes with that
he does acknowledge that in a way
in a very important
sense what we do know is confined to
what we perceive
but being that we are rational minds we
also go beyond what we perceive
anyway
so my interest in khan came from that he
acknowledges this life of the mind which
is more than just the life of the census
and he also acknowledges that there are
certain
benefits as well as costs that come with
that
benefits is that we can ask all sorts of
questions that go beyond what we
perceive and the cost says well there's
nothing or there's very little that pegs
us
to
anything that would
verify what it is that we are talking
about and what we are
asking about
um so in light of this what's important
for kant is that we're
as rational beings are boeing are both
knowers and
agents
in other words we have an interest in
knowing what the world is like
but we also have an interest in acting
in the world
and so some of the questions that go
beyond
what we perceive
come from that we don't only seek to
know what the world is like but we also
seek to act in the world
all right let me get straight to the
point um as agents
as uh beings that are interested in
acting in the world
we conceive of ourselves as free
and the other
traditionally what you would
free will
uh the thought being that
so
i have to decide about what i'm going to
do i can stay here i can get up
i can do this or i can do that and
obviously in order for me to
choose
one or the other thing i have to think
of myself as free in some sense
on the other hand everything that i see
in the world seems to operate according
to
cause and effect
so there comes the first issue that kant
would like to
say is crucial for us with which our
philosophizing begins
how is it that everything in the world
operates according to cause and effect
and i am a being in the world and yet i
think of myself as having free will
so either i as a being in the world i'm
operating according to cause and effect
like all things in the world
or
i'm somehow beyond the world as a being
that has free will
again this is an indicator of that as
rational beings
we consider ourselves as so much more
than just what we perceive of the world
outside ourselves
and even so much more than how we
perceive ourselves as beings in the
world in other words
uh the key here is that i can certainly
perceive myself in the world and that's
my body
but i'm also aware of myself as a
thinker
and uh it is in my thinking that i think
of myself as
a free woman and this aspect of me which
is free will doesn't really appear to my
senses or
to my perception
so yeah someone who's interested in the
issues of
free will as opposed to the issues uh as
opposed to cause and effect
by a means of which we know what happens
in the world
someone who's interested in thinking of
themselves as a being
free will
someone who's interested in thinking
them of themselves as a thinker that
asks questions
that go beyond what we can perceive in
the world
so for someone who conceives of
themselves in this way can't should be
very very interesting
because he tries to sort these things
out how is it that we can
make sense of the world as
taking place according to cause and
effect
and yet think of ourselves as free
beings that are somehow both in the
world and not in the world and of course
in order to resolve all these issues
kant makes all sorts of
interesting distinctions like uh
the distinctions between the a priori
knowledge and a posteriori knowledge
distinctions between synthetic judgments
and analytic judgments
and the question of metaphysics really
comes up in con in response to this
issue how is it that everything that is
sensible operates according to cause and
effect and yet i conceive of myself as
someone who is beyond cause and effect
and in that sense is somehow super
sensible
and so how is it
that there is a sensible world that
operates according to cause and effect
and then there is me who thinks of
myself as beyond cause and effect can i
be both sensible and super sensible
how do these two realms interact with
each other
the sensible and the super sensible
um
yeah
all these issues
that we would think about independently
can't respond to
but
i think
perhaps i have said both too much and uh
not enough
um
perhaps because i've been talking about
the same topic and not enough because i
haven't gone beyond perhaps you can help
me out greg how can i go beyond what i
said
well you know one of the things that was
particularly interesting is how you
started out
talking about kant being concerned with
questions
that necessarily overshoot
what we can at first you're talking in
terms of perception and you know having
knowledge in that sense
and then you started talking about about
verifying because a lot of people think
that
the way that you're going to verify
just about anything
is with with something that we call a
fact you know some sort of experience
and there's some things that that's fine
with you know is the coffee hot or is
the coffee cold well you better actually
taste it and find out uh is it actually
coffee or is it kerosene you know again
taste it and and find out but so many of
the the big things that were interested
in philosophy
um
they you know they they do go beyond
that and and i think you're right
[ __ ] is is uh
laying down some sort of barriers and
saying
you're not going to be able to deal with
these things by just looking around or
or even by drawing inferences based on
sensible data
so he's freeing us in a way but then the
question is well how do we decide these
these sorts of issues
so that's kind of a good launching point
there's this freedom on the one hand
from being just chained to empirical
phenomena
um or appeals to empirical phenomena but
then on the other hand doesn't that open
up this this sort of prospect that's
like this golf what do we do now
right
uh what do we do now
well maybe that's another way to look at
uh let's bring up the old question of
which philosophy begins and that's the
socratic question
and the question is uh how should i live
here comes socrates and he says look our
interest in philosophy begins with the
question of how should i live rather
than the question of
how does the world begin
addresses
that kind of an interest and his answer
to the question how should i live
um
the thought is that i should live as a
free being
um free being in what sense
in the sense that i'm going to
think about issues for myself
i'm going to
lives according to what i know
and
i'm going to be this is a catchphrase
with god i'm going to be thinking for
myself
um
um
i mean then the question might be well
what does it mean
to live as a free being
and uh
khan's answer here is both interesting
and paradoxical he'd like to say uh the
point of uh free will is simply to be
free
otherwise it uh
would be burdened down by all sorts of
things and not be
free
uh
okay and then i guess the question would
arise
how is it that my freedom is possible
well
maybe let's start it this way um
i like to start with the will i take it
that's the real issue in khan
um
to will and to both really isn't simply
to think and isn't simply to make
decisions in one's mind it is after all
to decide about how i'm going to act
yeah and if we're going to talk about
how i'm going to act
actions are going to have to take place
in the world not in my mind [ __ ] makes
an important distinction between
will and fantasy depend something that
simply takes place in my mind these are
wishes
but uh the will is something that i
decide to do and then follow up and act
and do in the world
and then the question very quickly
becomes
um
will the world play along
with my actions in the world
and that i guess arises in two ways
is the world such that it can receive
my
actions of freedom in the world or will
it stand in my way
or the other way in which this question
arises is
well but isn't it the world that makes
me choose to externalize in the world
this or that choice
so maybe those are two ways in which we
can think of how khan gets from ethics
and freedom to metaphysics
yeah you know he talks about the will as
being
a cause
you know i
insofar as i have a will or i am i am
well the will is practical reason
um i'm able to make things happen
i'm able to determine myself
so
i mean that's one expression of the the
pull of freedom and you mentioned that
to to be to really be free means
requiring valuing being free right um
but then you know
one of the worries that could come up
with that is what what does that
actually mean that's where that's where
duty and uh
and and reason
come in
and
um yeah that's there's there's almost a
paradox there too isn't there you're
gonna talk i think quite a bit about
autonomy but in order to be autonomous
one has to subject oneself to something
but what is one subjecting oneself to
it's not stuff out there in the world
it's
you know what rationality has revealed
to me as
the rational thing to do
um
well i guess
the starting point here i mean maybe
we'll start at the
easier way
that one how does one come to know
oneself as
free being perhaps in this way also
when i find myself
being manipulated by someone else
right away i respond hey this is wrong
yeah i'm being the truth is for myself
so there's our first clue our first clue
is
um
to be free is to be
unmanipulated uh now what does it mean
to be manipulated well that means
someone else decides for me
what it is that i'm going to do
otherwise
they could just simply ask me to do
those things
and
they would be happy with me doing them
or not doing them but they suspect that
i'm not going to do those things so
they're going to manipulate me
likewise i may suspect that someone else
is not going to do what i would like
them to do so i would engage
in
manipulating them by telling them
things that aren't really true
so then on the basis of these things
they would decide to do things that they
wouldn't
do if they knew what the truth was
yeah if they had full information yeah
so there's the founding experience um
am i being manipulated by someone else
and there are a couple of things that i
would like the easiest way to get there
would be to manipulate someone else but
as soon as that happens i know that
just as it is morally problematic for me
to be violated to be manipulated
it seems that right away i know that
it is morally wrong for me to manipulate
someone else
and in that i'm acknowledging that i am
a being of free will
and hence there is a problem with
manipulation
just as this other person too must be a
being with free will
and hence
uh there's a problem with manipulating
that other person
you know that that brings up an
interesting point earlier you were
talking about realizing
um the self as being beyond cause and
effect and so
you know the universalization that's
required for from a reality realizing
that i don't like you know such as i
don't like this being done to me i feel
that there's there's a wrong being done
to me
and for me to do it to somebody else
to to transgress
against them and against duty in that
way
is to to realize them as as likewise
being beyond cause and effect it's it's
almost uh
doesn't say it this way but it's to have
sort of a
metaphysical view of the the other
um yeah yeah yeah there is something to
be said about my recognition
of the other being as being a free will
i'm going to stay for metaphysics for
just another moment i'm going to use
this as an opportunity to talk about the
universal law
okay
so here i am i recognize myself
as being manipulated and that being
contrary to my free will and i recognize
that for me to manipulate someone else
but also be wrong in that it's contrary
to their free will
so then the thought becomes that i
should only act
in such a way that
the other person could also will
or i should act with regard to that
other person
not in such a way that they wouldn't
will to be acted
with
so
i take it that this is the real ground
for the universal law and god it's not
simply that i think uh in terms of the
law for the sake of the law itself
but there is this foundation that
i should only do those things
that
other free wills would consent to
and so roughly that turns out to be that
i should be doing
those things which have a form of a law
in the sense that i consent to these
things and also others consent to these
things
would like to suggest that as the origin
of
this i like that because that's a nice
way to bring together
the you know the first two formulations
of the categorical imperative
um
you know the first one emphasizes
universalization and also being able to
will something as a universal law of
nature so that if it's okay for you then
better be okay across the board you know
but the second one gets us to to
something more at the heart of the
matter if i'm if i'm going to say uh
that something is is not okay for me
because i'm a rational being and i
shouldn't be in the for example
manipulated or
or pressured or pick whatever sorts of
things my autonomy ought to be respected
that i ought to
likewise respect the autonomy of of
others
um and you know i think sometimes
i i see this problem with with my
students when i'm teaching this they
don't they don't see i probably don't
spend enough time on this how the
formulations actually
uh connect with each other
they see them almost like two separate
tests
and kant clearly thought they were
you know intimately connected
so the formulation that you were giving
there is a nice way of doing that i
think
yeah um all right i'm gonna
i'm going to find my way back into
metaphysics as
i see uh that's what your viewers are
interested in but let me put it this way
uh so there are two possible sources of
manipulation here it would be another
person's will
but another source of manipulation that
front is worried about and i think we
all are is our own desires
yeah in other words every once in a
while i experience a desire and it's
just so strong that
i'm compelled by that desire
and if indeed i'm compelled by desire in
that way then
how can i speak of myself as having a
free will
so
for kant
and i think it's not a bad way for us to
think about it as well
as if we are going to be beings of free
will
we are going to have to be able to rise
above
being compelled by our own desires
okay and so i'll discuss
the possibilities of that
but before that let me say that we are
indeed finding our way back into the
metaphysics here
in the sense that kant is thinking that
our desires are
bodily or at any rate they are through
the body
and uh the body is in the physical world
where where everything operates
according to cause and effect so
really thinks that
uh insofar as i'm subject to my desire
i'm subject to cause and effect that
operates
in the world which influences me through
my desire in other words
i don't choose the things that i like i
don't choose the things that give me
pleasure
i don't choose the things that i dislike
i don't choose the things that are
painful i simply find myself being
pained by certain things and i find
myself being pleased by other things
so in order for us
to be able to speak of ourselves as
beings of free will we're going to have
to give an account of how we are somehow
above
uh
desire which operates according to cause
and effect
all right so obviously cause and effect
is the big issue here and there are two
ways to talk uh to find our way
there are two ways to find ourselves
talking war being worried about cause
and effect
one
uh how do i know that cause and effect
operates out there in the world because
after all in order for me to understand
anything about the world i have to think
about it in terms of cause and effect
and two
how can i be free of cause and effect
meaning how can i be free of compelling
compulsions of my desire
two ways of finding our way
into the metaphysics of positive effect
and i can go to that now or i can
see what you want to say at this point
right well let's try let's do the first
one um sort of the human
problem that that that kant thought was
really you know needing to be addressed
because you know
it seems like hume is is uh
this corrosive
uh influence
he's saying yeah you people out there
you think that there really are causes
and effects and that's just really a
matter of habit you've perceived things
to occur this way and then you make this
this unfounded inference and it's okay
because you know we still have to have
the billiard balls you know when we're
playing pool
um we still have to
step outside of the the uh the
philosopher's study and be able to get
by in life but really at the bottom
you can never really be sure of anything
um
and so count really took that to heart
and you might say well you gotta swing
to the other extreme and say cause and
effect definitely are out there
out in the world
and
that's not what kant is actually
saying in the sense that you know the
external reality is there before any
subject is is perceiving it right so
he's doing something com
not completely different but something
this is where the the copernican term
comes in doesn't it
yeah
um so
hume introduces some suspicions
about whether cause and effect is real
or whether cause and effect isn't simply
a convenient fiction
that we construct for ourselves in order
to make sense of the world
all right so let me just go to an
example real quickly here um
we bring fire to paper
and the paper has no choice but
to ignite and burn as a result of uh
fire being brought to it you know under
normal circumstances yeah
so this is what we call cause and effect
um
that it could not have been the case
that the paper didn't work
the paper had no options but to burn
when the fire has been brought near to
it
and because we think that the world
operates in this way that every time i
bring fire to paper it's going to burn
i can infer what has happened in the
world in the past given what i perceive
in the present and i can also predict
about what happens in the future
given what happens in the present
and you of course says now look you look
at the fire you look at the paper and
all you see is fire and paper you don't
see any cause and effect
uh on the one hand you don't see any
cause and effect
and on the other hand
and this is really the the big deal
about not seeing cause and effect is
we don't ex we don't experience there
being any necessity
about the fire necessarily burning paper
what we experienced is that well it just
so happened that the fair the paper did
catch on fire
we don't experience that it couldn't
possibly have been otherwise that the
paper didn't catch on fire for all we
know that might have been the case it
may have been the case that the paper
didn't catch on fire but it just so
happens that it did granted this happens
every time
but you know it just so happens that it
happens every time
we think that there is necessity
operating here but we don't actually
perceive any necessity out there
and you
really wanting to peg our knowledge of
the world to what we perceive had a
problem with this since we don't
perceive
this most essential of all the relations
that we
use to make sense of the world cause and
effect
and so here comes cotton
and what is khan's point
khan's point is well yes indeed we don't
perceive cause and effect out there
but
we have no option but to think that
cause and effect operates
and
we haven't well this is god's point uh
we have no option
but say a bit more about what that
thinking
is
uh you know this is where concepts come
in right the way concepts have to be
connected with each other
right positive effect is one of those
i mean the concept here that we're
discussing we can talk about all sorts
of concepts but it just so happens that
we're talking about positive effect
uh
so here comes companies like
look i i look at the fire
in order for me to experience it as a
fire
i have to think that it's going to burn
certain things
and that it's going to be doused by
water
of course i don't perceive any of this
as i'm looking at the fire
but this is what i have to think in
order to experience it as a fire at all
so
john's point is that in order for us to
have any experience at all
it isn't just their perceptions
uh that experience has to be
conceptually loaded
in this way so to speak
that concepts are always already
operating there
uh the concepts are always already
operating there in order for us to have
experience at all
and the concepts are always already
operating there in order for how for us
to have knowledge
and
so the point here being
that the the very question of
how do i know
that the world doesn't actually have
cause and effect doesn't make sense
given that knowledge by its very nature
already includes cause and effect
or other kinds of concepts
um all right but of course the old
problem is there we don't perceive this
stuff so it must be the case
that
knowledge and experience and
this is the more controversial point but
i think god makes it
uh knowledge and experience and the very
reality itself
uh
contains cause and effect and other
conceptually mediated relations or i'll
just say other concepts
because
experience knowledge and reality itself
is
constituted by our thinking in part
and this is the copernican revolution
um
all right so in order to make sense of
this of course we're going to have to
say
yeah sure experience knowledge and
reality
necessarily have to cause and have to
have positive
other
concepts of that great importance but
that's just experience knowledge and
reality for us
and the crown's point is well yes but
that is really all we ever mean
experience knowledge and reality
is that it's always for us
in other words it simply doesn't make
sense
to say how do i know through experience
what things are like independently of
experience
how do i know
through
perception and thinking
what things are like independently of
perception of thinking
that the very question here is absurd
well it's not absurd but this is not the
right context for it
so
this is actually a good launching point
then to to
go into something that that comes up a
little bit before these
um with one of the questions that that
somebody is is asking and this is not in
the q a app but this was posted earlier
on the
the uh event page
this the first part
i think i know i could talk about and
you could talk about maybe you can also
talk about the second part i can't
so he said this is from kevin gonzalez
that he says
an explanation of kant's views on space
and time would be would be very nice and
how we can relate it to the modern day
string theory and physics so i don't
know enough about modern day string
theory to actually say anything
intelligent about it um
but how is space and time different than
say
cause and effect for kant i think that's
a good question to to launch into
yeah
yeah
all right
so
i think we have no option but to talk
about the necessity and universality
um so
the founding point here that trump wants
to make is that in order for anything to
make rational sense
there has to be some sort of necessity
and universality operating there
so let me go back to the paper and the
fire and then i'll i now work my way
into
space and time from there
so
there must be universality involved here
in the sense that the paper doesn't just
burn fire here and here and here where i
happen to have observed it
but the paper must burn fire anywhere in
the universe under the same
conditions so we have here something
like
homogeneity of space
or i should say that
in order for laws of cause and effect to
be universal space must be homogenous
scientists call this sort of a thing the
uniformity of nature
in order for what i observe about cause
and effect between paper and fire
to
be meaningful beyond just those specific
places where i observe it
um cause and effect must be universal in
its nature and space must be uniform
universal
so i can put
uh so there cannot be any irregularities
in space there cannot be any exceptions
in other words space
in order for my meat to have knowledge
about causal properties of fire
it has to fire has to have those causal
properties anywhere in space
because if uh certain spots in space
were different
then there these causal properties of
fire will not be operating and what i
know about fire would be no
in those
locations in space
so
space must be
uniform
and
then the question becomes
well how do i know that the space is
uniform
on the one hand
i know that space must be uniform in
order from for there to be any knowledge
at all
and given that there is knowledge
that therefore space is uniform
so
i know that space must be uniform but it
isn't something that i perceive because
i certainly don't perceive
the entirety of space
so transport us space must be something
that we
bring to experience
it must be something that we bring to
experience
an independent layer of perception
space is a kind of uh
so there are two things about space on
the one hand space makes a universality
of laws about cause and effect and other
things possible
and on the other hand space has the
structure of being a kind of a grid
um all right so the second thing that's
essential about space is this
it's gonna sound simple but
it's simple and crucial at the same time
and here it is
two things
can't be in the same
place and space at the same time
one thing is this is absolutely crucial
two things cannot be in the same
location in space at the same time
now
all right so
in order for any of our thinking about
the world and nature to make sense we
are thinking this sort of a thing of
course this is not something we know
through perception because we haven't
been
we haven't been everywhere in the world
and we cannot say that this is the case
so space has these necessary and
universal structures one of them being
the two things can't be
in the same place at the same time
and kant is going to ask well how is
that possible well certainly not through
perception this is some kind of a
pre-experiential structure that we
bring to experience
all right i'm going to say a bit more
here uh the issue here is this
as it turns out in this discussion space
isn't something out there that we
perceive
but space is something that we bring to
experience
from within the mind
now
this was
always a point of contention
historically
is space something out there to be
perceived
or space
something that we think about
in order to make some sense of things in
other words no one
you know with the exception of barkley
no one's really ever doubted that there
are things out there
but we in order to make sense of those
things that are out there we have to say
that they are in space
but what we observe are just things we
don't observe space
so some folks said uh sure space is this
real structure out there that we observe
and you can see why that will be
problematic
and then there were other folks who said
no space is not out there space is
something
that the mind brings to experience in
order to make sense of what's out there
all right so kant is obviously on the
letter
side of this debate
um
so i take that string theory folks
and
some of the other
post newtonian theories in physics
probably want to make claims like that
it is in fact possible for two things to
be in the same location
in space at the same time
or let me put it this way those are the
kinds of claims that they would have to
make in order to have contention
okay
and
so all right so now folks start talking
about curved space and
space and other ways as well
um
all right so let me
just very quickly say a few things about
time so just as kind goes it is a
necessary structure of space
that two things can't be in the same
location and space at the same time
what's the are there any necessary
universal structures to time yes there
are
and here is the necessary universal
structure of time
things happen one after another
uh again so the point is that this is
necessarily and universally the case
because this is the only way we are able
to make sense of events
things happen one after another
in other words there is a sense that the
future is not here yet
and there is a sense that there was some
past before this present
and the flow
of time is always forward
first there is uh past that there's
present then there's future
it doesn't go back and forth sometimes
this way sometimes that way but it's
necessarily and always forward think
about it this way if that wasn't the
case
then how can i make any knowledge claims
about the world
and if that wasn't the case how can i
have any kind of a coherent experience
of the world
so there are these necessary and
universal structures to space and time
and again necessity and universality
isn't something we observe out there so
it must be something that we bring to
experience from within the mind
um
so the point of contention from
contemporary physics would be
they would have to say things like no
things can be in space
uh in the same space at the same time
and
they should be saying things like sure
time can flow forward time can go
backward
so those are the if those are the sorts
of claims that the contemporary theories
and physics are making then in fact
there will be a point of contention
with kant there
uh
well
do i have a comment about this i do
um
i take it that khan's point would be
that
for the sake of theorization in physics
we may have to assume
that two things can be
in the same place at the same time we
may have to assume that time flows back
and forth
but in order for us to make sense of
those assumptions
we have to somehow graft them onto the
usual structure of thinking
and that two places
that two things cannot be in space at
the same time
and that time flows forward
we would have to think in those terms
about these weird abnormalities these
would be local exceptions right
these would be sort of local exceptions
but the
they would only be exceptions
here here here and there'd have to be
some way of explaining why they can be
an exception here
or here as opposed to being
possibilities everywhere
yeah yeah yeah so the starting point is
certainly the time space grid that kant
puts forth
uh
and that and we are thinking about all
of these things as deviations from that
grid
because the point here being is that
these time and space grids that kant
wants to talk about they're not simply
time and space grades of newtonian
physics
time and space grants of things making
sense to us
at all
in other words if somehow we had
intimations of that reality was somehow
not quite like that
this is how we would have to make sense
of it
okay
let's let's take some of the uh
questions from the q and a
list um
i'm not sure which order they came in
but i'm gonna put them in a somewhat
different order than they are in the
queue
let me try with this one um if i may
sure question whether conference and
dental idealism
uh
whether it is an epistemological theory
or whether it is a of physical theory
of the philosophy of mind
all right so
what khan does is he destroys the
distinction
between all those things
uh
in other words if we're doing philosophy
of mind in the continent sense we're not
just talking about mind we're talking
about how we know
and we have no business of speaking
about reality independently of how we
know it
so
what we are getting in con is at the
same time
uh theory of knowledge
epistemology
uh
theory of metaphysics theory of reality
which is metaphysics and since all of
this is
based on
what we think the mind is like
then this is also philosophy of mind as
well
but of course we can draw a distinction
between these things as i
you know in order for me to destroy
those distinctions a moment ago i had to
first make them
um well philosophy of mind in the
conventional sense refers
to the difference between
the body and the mind does can't make a
distinction between the mind and the
body as he does
but
he would also say that we are not able
to talk about experience knowledge and
reality
without speaking about them
so in that sense the distinction is not
there
but we can still draw the distinction in
another con
okay so that one's neatly dealt with um
let's uh
let's do
let's
well i think this one's already been
dealt with can we experience things that
we don't sense don't affect us and
necessarily don't exist to an autonomous
agent
you know
can you experience things that that you
don't experience no right
that we you talked about earlier
right
um
but maybe the thing to be said a few
things about here is
so on the one hand kant would like to
say that
reality is not mind independent
that the mind constitutes with by means
of these concepts and categories that
simply cannot be avoided
but at the same time kant would like to
say that there is a portion of reality
that's unknown yeah
so on one hand
uh knowledge is off reality
and reality is knowable but at the same
time there is a portion of reality
which is unknowable so
there's a bit of attention here but
thinkable
sorry
but thinkable
yes it would be thinkable
but
in order for something to be known
it has to be not merely thinkable it
also has to be sensible yeah it makes a
distinction between
the thinkable and the knowable
indeed we can think much more than we
that we can know
hence uh the first line of the critique
of fewer reasons we ask ourselves
questions that we cannot answer he means
we ask ourselves questions that we
cannot answer from the standpoint of now
if we take it that what we know
has to be sensible as well all right so
the point being here is this um
that kant is thinking that there is
something
which we sense and think about
and our sensing it and thinking about it
constructs experience knowledge and
reality for us
but then of course there is also that
original something
of which we which we
experience of which we form
sensations and experience so that
original something kant would like to
say
is unknowable
it's what he calls the thing in itself
of which we experience no
and no appearances only as they must be
according to our organs of perception
and according to our thinking
i think of ourselves as as free beings
fits in there as well right
right so
yeah that point can be quickly
established now
um
so
the appearances of
that we know that we experience
the reality that we know and experience
must be according to cause and effect
but then there is also that unknowable
reality which is the source of these
appearances in our experience and
knowledge
and you know it is beyond cause and
effect since cause and effect operates
only in that portion
which appears to us
and
cause and effect operates only in that
portion which is knowable to us so if
there is an unknowable portion of
reality then cause and effect does not
operate there or rather
there is no way for us to say
whether cause and effect operates there
or not but doesn't it seem like there
there is at least one
form of cause
the the free cause ourselves deciding to
how we're going to determine ourselves
that that does at least come out of
there and then once it emerges into the
world now of course we're in the world
of you know determined phenomena um
appearances
yeah
so if we are going to think about free
will at all and if that's how we think
of ourselves fundamentally it's going to
have to reside in that unknowable
portion
if anywhere yeah
to be there
doesn't that mean this is one of the
worries that i think some people have
about kant that everything that's
determinate about us
um
you know the structures of our
personality uh our our histories our
relationships all of that is within this
conditioned world
of appearances
and
in a certain sense isn't really who i am
you know as far as freedom goes as far
as morality goes none of that stuff is
really that important
um but then you know i i would like to
look at most of that and say well that's
that's who i am that's my individuality
this seems to be one of the worries that
a lot of people
bring to the table with kant
well we have to remember that
as well as i think
in our own experience we are both
we are both the freedom
which is not determined by specific
relationships we find
ourselves in
and
we are
situated in those relationships and we
must respond to them and we are formed
by those relationships so there is this
deeply personalized and unique aspect of
what we are
yeah
also in addition to that
there is
that
pure freedom and it's so pure that it's
unpersonalized to any extent
that's a nice way to put it
unpersonalized rather than impersonal
you know
um
yes yes yes i guess that is a nice way
you know i'm
reminded of of something so descartes in
in talking about the union of the mind
and the body and his his uh
uh i don't remember whether this is in
the correspondence with princess
elizabeth or the passions of the soul
which is more or less written to her
he's he says you know you can think
about things
from the perspective of the body you can
think about the mind you can think about
the union of the the
the mind and the body and here's what
it's really hard to think of at the same
time it's hard to think of the mind and
body as distinct
and yet
with their union at the same time i try
to keep those all in my head
and they all fall apart
and this is descartes of course he's
saying that about him and i don't think
it's it's false humility on his part and
isn't there something sort of like that
in kant this this having to think of
ourselves
in terms of the realm of appearances and
at the same time as this
radically free
but unknowable
agency of some sort it's hard to to to
put them together and yet that's that
you know that's
according to the conscient point of view
what we are we're both of those
i have a hard time myself
not you know i can think about it this
side
and then i'm thinking over here and i
can think about this and i'm thinking
over here but to actually keep them
together is really a challenge
all right well i think what's going on
here is uh
we have two ways of relating
to reality
through our senses
and through our thinking
right we experience ourselves as in the
one hand sensing
and on the other hand this thinking
in other words we experience ourselves
as sensing in the sense that we are
operating with images
but we also experience ourselves as
thinking without images as well
like
you know when i simply think to myself
or when i speak
i may bring images to bear to what i'm
thinking
but i can also think about those images
and my thinking about those images isn't
just more images
my thinking about those images is
something altogether out other than
images it is not
how should i put it imaginable
yeah um
so
comment as well as descartes would say
well
have an experience of yourself engaged
in thinking
without images
and
that's what you are as that
being that is beyond the sensible
so you can have an experience i mean
descartes says okay i have a concrete
experience of it i can
think that all that i see isn't
real and
i can just think without images i think
deckard has both of those things
he tends to when he's talking and um
you know i think this is more in his
correspondence with people he'll he'll
say things like well you know we're
thinking in terms of just through our
senses
this is the wrong way to put it because
we don't think through our senses that's
very easy to do and thinking with the
images
you know carrying out imaginary stuff
that's pretty easy to do
thinking with the pure intellect alone
that's very tough maybe you can do that
for a few minutes out of a day you know
and that's that's about as far as you're
going to get with it with kant it seems
like no you could actually do it quite a
lot of the time
uh
well
thinking
i mean it just seems to me that thinking
is searches without images
uh
like you know right now i'm speaking and
uh it's making perfect sense to me and
i'm not having all these images
yeah
i mean there's there's images in the
sense of sight images and then there's
there's the the hearing itself is is
also images right forced elegant
uh
they're just not
i guess we need to make the distinction
this way uh images
are of particular things
okay whereas thinking operates with
concepts yeah yeah about
universals
which are not
particular things
so
indeed i have very particular sounds
as i'm speaking right the sound of my
voice is different than the sound of
your voice
but
the point here isn't
the uniqueness of my voice the point
here
are the concepts what's being
communicated
so and i think you know there's an
experience of those concepts as such
independently of
the auditory image
okay
let's take a couple uh
questions that
are um
you might say
pedagogical and about the history of
ideas let's look at this one and let's
say you can only pick one work
uh this is by christopher dunn
what do you guys think would be the most
influential work that kant came up with
in his lifetime so you can only pick one
book
that's kind of that's tough for me
um
well
i mean would it have to be one of the
critiques
yeah
yeah it would have to be one of the
critiques uh it wouldn't be the third
one sorry i know that sort of most uh
hotly
hated one
i would either be the first one or the
second one and i'm tempted to say the
second one really
you know
when i first thought about it i was i
was leaning towards the second because
you know me i'm i'm more about moral
philosophy than than epistemology anyway
but then i started thinking where has he
had
i don't that's very tough where has he
had the most influence
it's very difficult to decide between
the first and the second critique
because even if you don't like where
kant went
you can't avoid
engaging him right
yeah yeah yeah yeah
and from that standpoint is the first
critique more important than the second
one
i mean what is it that's tough for god
that's a from god
that he brings for us
uh it's precisely what we've been
talking about
that there is something
that takes place
that is mental
and
that is not just sensory but to make it
more radical
this mental stuff that is not sensory is
the foundation
yeah
the sensory stuff being meaningful to us
meaningful either as
uh knowledge
or meaningful as
something we must
choose with regard to
um
so
let me just put it blankly
and that is the most difficult thing to
swallow
or a contemporary thinker
yeah you know when i think about it in
terms of the history of ideas
so there would be no german idealism
without kant
um
because that that that notion that the
the subject and so many you know these
idealists are diverging from content
just precisely how this works and what
the categories might be and
do they develop do they you know are
they are they more you know once and for
all um but this this copernican turn
towards the the subject as
to some degree constituting the world of
experience that they can be involved in
so that's that's the first critique and
it's very tempting to say
that's the seminal insight and yet
you know
you look at um
hegel or schopenhauer or or
you know victor or any of these these
people the the moral
can't be extricated from that
um so the content of the second critique
how does desire actually function
you know um what is it to to actually
um
choose rightly these things
are are intimately
tied in i mean here would be an
interesting question
what if he only had the first two
critiques would we really be missing
something uh vital by not having the
third critique
well
um
i think yes
there's a you know there's an
influential important and good
account of experience of the beautiful
the sublime
yeah and uh the teleology of the third
critique is also
important
uh so
it's important but you know it's so to
speak putting the flesh onto the
skeleton the skeleton is in the those
first two critiques
do you think
that i mean con encounter of the um
the proligomena and
the um
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
is doing
something similar to what's going on in
in the critiques
um i mean the groundwork is the
groundwork for the metaphysics of morals
and that's that's that's a separate work
um but do you think that these are
like when we're teaching this do you
think it's it's helpful to have students
read those before going into the the
first and the second critique let's say
we actually had enough time to have
students read all of this stuff which we
never do
um the groundwork is perfectly
a perfectly good introduction to france
moral thinking
um
all the important stuff from the second
critique is already there
in the groundwork
there is not
an emphasis on free will in the ground
which is the centerpiece yeah the
practical reason so the metaphysics of
it
is in the critique of practical reason
but
so to speak the phenomena
let me put it this way so the
phenomenology of the moral experience is
in the groundwork
uh you know our experience of the world
metaphysics uh
right the metaphysics of morality
is in uh the second critique
that's where the question is really
worked out
how can free will and the
knowledge of the sensible world
being bought
together
put together
uh the prodigame in which khan has sort
of written the
chapter by chapter summary
of the first critique i haven't read it
i haven't looked at it for a while
because i remember having to read it as
an undergraduate and then in graduate
school
um
and my impression was
if you want to read the first critique
read the first critique and that the
prologum and uh at least when i was an
undergrad i found very confusing
um but then again i didn't have very
good teachers when i was an
undergraduate
uh they just sort of assigned us things
and then
introduction you really only just need
to read the two prefaces
and the introduction to the first
critique
yeah
way with reading the two prefaces
i mean if you're interested in minutia
like the analytic and synthetic
judgments
then yeah you should go into
introduction
space and time
yeah you're interested in
the project
that the first two prefaces are gonna do
it for you
let's let's look at this other question
then and maybe maybe you actually um
will
disagree with the question itself
what is it about
kant that makes him
notoriously murky in in in reading
through him
this is something that we've talked
about a bit off off air
um
i mean i think it's in in part for the
challenge for a lot of people is the
terminology yeah
yeah i would have to agree uh
yeah i mean i would just
pretty much leave it there it's the
terminology
i found that to be the biggest challenge
yeah uh the terminology well we can
probably say more it's the terminology
and the grammar of it sure
and
perhaps i should say this
goes uh i'm just giving the outlines
here i'm just giving the bare bones
somebody later can come in and put in
the examples
and applications and things like that
i am going to just lay down the
structure
now that actually
points to something so you know for
example in the beginning of this
when you were talking about um the
example of
manipulation
it seems like if we don't have these
examples
it is hard to
to figure out um
what he's talking about sometimes but
you know kant himself says i don't want
anything to depend on examples you know
that's that's a that's not the way to go
about this this sort of stuff
in the uh
the groundwork for the metaphysics of
morals
um
i know for me it's very helpful to have
examples
what do you what's your take on that
you're gonna
read it very
slowly uh and you know if you have the
patience and the interest
reading it that slowly
yeah you don't need the examples much
uh if you're only going to do it once
and quickly
without too much patience or interest
then the examples would be
key
i can't picture anybody
reading count through just once and and
getting a hell of a lot out of it
yeah perhaps that's part part of the
problem with some of our undergraduates
you know
they think they can they can read it
like reading um
a newspaper or or a novel or something
along those lines
uh yeah i'm sure
some types of philosophical writings
yeah well the groundwork is pretty
straightforward maybe the groundwork can
be read as such
i do find that my students get caught up
in
the terminology in the groundwork and
they also have trouble
you know seeing how to move from from
paragraph to paragraph um they think he
jumps around a lot he's not
everything in there is is you know where
it needs to be
but they don't see the but i want to
come back to the issue of desire
okay
just
so
this is a founding experience for god i
like to speak about experiences that
khan must be playing off
and here's one of them he goes for me to
simply comply with my desires
no dignity there meredith
for me to rise above my desire
there
there is the dignity of the human being
and this dignity is due to that this
human being has
a rational mind
now it's hard for me to say
it's hard for me to see how
anyone would disagree with khan
what are your thoughts
well i mean there's something like that
going on in plato in the republic you
know he derives
the um parts of the soul by starting
with
our desires our appetites
and that notes that reason sometimes
tells us don't do that you know don't
eat all that
don't go and have
he doesn't use he's not quite so cruises
don't go and have sex with that person
um
stop because because the desires are
unable to uh
to place
checks upon themselves so he says well
there must be two at least two parts of
the soul and then of course he you know
he goes on and
finds the most which
you know it's very difficult to figure
out exactly what that is
um
but yeah i think you know here's here's
the worry
that kant sort of introduces
um
so let's say i do you know i i don't
give in to my desire
and now i congratulate myself on aha
what great dignity i have
because i've managed to resist my desire
perhaps i have a desire to think of
myself as uh such a swell guy
um
you know to engage in self approbation
uh that would be just as as as much
dictated by the you know the laws
pertaining to the
the purely phenomenal as that original
desire so i
and it seems like constance but you
never can be quite sure that self-love
in one form or another doesn't really
lie at the bottom of you have to think
that it doesn't yeah
but you could never really be completely
sure but what's this obsession with
being sure about
ah yeah motives
that you figure out what the right thing
to do is and you do and you do it to the
best of your ability
and
you can
spend time
questioning the purity of your motives
or you can just use that time to make
that much more of an effort to do what
is right
yeah
i take it khan has something like this
in mind it's not the
i mean he acknowledges that we don't
have that kind of deep self knowledge
that we know our precise motives but
he didn't think that was a big deal and
i think we have to ask why he didn't
think that was a big deal and who is a
person
who is just going to sit there and dwell
and whether their motives were 100
percent fewer only 98
well it's almost like uh
cartesian hyperbolic doubt applied in
the world of morality isn't it
because you know unless you can be
absolutely
certain and notice you know cartesian
hyperbolic doubt is used to strip away
everything that's right but descartes
built
the whole philosophy of it yeah
mom thought it was irrelevant
well maybe in the realm of morals it
actually is
yeah
you know
let's um let's take another question
um
the way that kant speaks about
aesthetics so we're talking about the
third critique is it possible to
conceptualize the sublime
uh is it possible to conceptualize the
sublime um
well
the question as you would put it this
word
perhaps not in the best way but i'll
just talk about
the sublime um so there are two types of
all right so what is the experience of
the sublime the experience of the
sublime is precisely the experience of
the superiority of the rational over the
sensible
uh it's the experience of the dignity of
it
yeah is this different from
self-deprivation that you spoke of a
little while ago
self-deprivation is a very interesting
kind of a thing
uh it is indeed one's desire that seeks
this self-approvation
in the rising above the sensible
but the aesthetic experience after all
would like to say is disinterested yes
so
you just
acknowledge
that
the rational rises above the sensible
you acknowledge it
you recognize it
you acknowledge the feeling that
accompanies that recognition
but all of this completely independently
without that search for self-absorption
all right so what is difficult to
conceptualize here
all right uh i mean i think i see what
the issue is there are two types of
sublime
uh one experience of the sublime is that
indeed
i rise above my desire
it's the moral experience of the supply
um
nothing too hard to conceptualize there
so i suspect that the question is about
the second type of supply
and the second type of sublime is about
something like
that i'm able to think the concept of
the infinite
and i'm able to think the concept of the
condition
these are not moral concepts these are
just
straightforward
concepts that any rational being is able
to have the concept of the unconditioned
is we can apply in morality but we also
don't have to
of the unconditioned
and the concept of the infinite
and then
you look around you
and you don't find anything infinite and
you don't find anything conditioned
or
better yet you try to make sense
out of these concepts of the
unconditioned
and
the infinite by looking at finite and
conditioned things right
and you kind of go well i just have to
keep adding more and more and more and
more and more of finite things to reach
infinity
i just have to
grasp the entirety of the condition to
get to the unconditioned
and then of course you realize that you
can
and once again you fear you feel
and recognize the dignity
of your rationality that produces these
concepts
which we can't make sense of
in terms of what we understand
okay but this is this but what's
interesting about khan is that
he wants to say it's not the infinity
out there
that i failed to conceptualize
it's not the unconditioned out there
that i failed to conceptualize
it's my own concept
of the infinite it's my own concept of
the unconditioned
that i failed to find anything like in
the world
all right so
what is the unconceptualizable here well
precisely the unconditioned
precisely the infinite so yes
uh
there is something that is beyond
conceptual at the foundation
well
add the foundation of these experiences
but yeah we can conceptualize what's
going on in the experience
yeah i mean insofar as we can actually
talk about it meaningfully and and break
down what's going on in it
aren't we doing so through concepts
yes yes so you're gonna have to
distinguish concepts that tell you
what's going on in there and then
concepts by means of which we're talking
about
what's going on in there
yeah
there's a certain kind of unconceptual
ability involved there but it's not
complete
we're also able to speak about it
okay
let's uh there's a number of people
who've given a plus one to this question
um kant is notorious for you know having
been quite strict in this matter
uh what are your thoughts on kant and
his duties on sexual impulse so i you
know the way i would interpret this is
his
one's duties vis-a-vis any sort of
sexual acts and sexual desire
well
from the standpoint of desire of course
they don't make any sense
from the standpoint of
you know the erotic the desiring aspect
of us they are
ridiculous but from the standpoint of
morality
they make a bit more sense um
all right so what is what's going on in
there um
i'll put it this way all right
here comes karma and he goes you know
there is your lover
with whom to whom you relate to by means
of your desire
but your
moral relation to that lover has nothing
to do with that desire
and you treat that lover as simply
another human being
so you know it's the old critique that
in this kind of moral thinking
we are so moral that we are moral to
strangers but then of course everyone is
a stranger yeah he's treated us exactly
alike those who we are intimate with and
those who we don't know
they have exactly the same status
of
being just
free wills that we relate to
okay but maybe what the question is
about
is uh
simply saying that when i experience the
sexual impulse
i am experiencing something animal like
i'm experiencing
some sort of a compulsion
and my dignity comes precisely from
being
beyond and above that compulsion
and being able to put it aside
yeah
um so there's nothing dignified about
the sexual influence i guess
that's what's going to be problematic
about god
well
so be it there's nothing morally
dignified about sexual impulse i mean
what would be the point of trying to
find something morally dignifying about
something
you know i think that with one of the
ques one of the things that may underlie
that is kant
gets brought up um from time to time as
being very puritanical when it came to
sexual morality
and
um being so
in part because he was buying into some
of the conceptions that were prevalent
about
the way the body worked um
back
back in the 18th century you know uh so
masturbation for example one should
absolutely not do that
uh because it's harmful to the body
um
turns out that you know nowadays
not a lot of people
scientifically think that that's the
case today i suppose it depends on how
you're doing it
i'm sure that what's that nothing
harmful to the body i'm sure or not
yeah and so
i think we have to distinguish the
things that kant would
um
that are coming safe from kant's
anthropology from a pragmatic point of
view which is entirely about the realm
of the the condition that we're supposed
to know something about through science
because he says a lot of
you know pretty funny stuff some some
that where you know you're actually
saying well i can't believe he said that
in in those kinds of uh works but that
doesn't have very much to do with with
the actual
uh moral questions
involved so i mean if it turns out that
we're wrong about some of the factual
assumptions
then you know
then we may have to revise uh
how we view things in a moral
perspective but not because we're
changing the morality we're just saying
look the way things apply in this case
is is different you know
um
interesting because i in my classes you
know when we talk about the second uh
formulation of categorical imperative
um
the classes always want to talk about
prostitution and whether you're using
the humanity within yourself as a mere
means
to to an end um and of course you know
count would say yeah of course you are
um so so you shouldn't be engaging in
that that sort of stuff
um guess there's not i i don't know i
don't actually have anything more to say
about content
sexual matters um
do you
um no but you know i mean
well
we have to distinguish between the
you know the principles of khan and
anyone else for that matter yeah
implications of those principles
and you know the philosopher may not do
so well in the application of those
principles but let's not throw the baby
away with the bath water
yeah the applications of the main
principles are a bit peculiar
that doesn't invalidate the principle
it's not necessary
right approach to those things let's
take one more question and then we'll
close up coincidentally we only have one
more question so and it's about time to
wrap up
uh this is by troy spell on desire what
part does his desire play in motivation
as far as acting on that desire and also
having the means or not having the means
to attain that desire so a bunch of
different questions all rolled up in one
okay
just seconds
what part does desire play in motivation
well a large part
desire is
what motivates us
we have two motivations there is the
motivation of desire and there is the
motivation of reason
desire is motivated by seeking things
that are pleasant and reason is
motivated by seeking
knowledge as well as the activity of the
free will
so we have two or three motivations um
now as far as i think
i mean desire can be without the means
to attain the desire
that seems to be
where he's going with that like if i if
i want to be a superstar
or the president or have a million bucks
in my pocket i can have that desire all
i want but doesn't make any difference
right
all right maybe i'll tackle it this way
um
there are two models about what reason
does in ethics with respect to desire
one is
that reason is just this thing by means
of which we can really efficiently
fulfill our desires
yeah this reason is the sort of a thing
that calculates all right i'm going to
forego desire a b and c so i can achieve
desire d and desire d is so much more
important than desires a b and c in
other words i will sacrifice some things
in the short run in order to obtain
other things in the long run
so this is all reason
in service of desire how to maximize
the attainment and fulfillment of
different desires that's one mod
of the relationship between reason and
desire and ethics
the other model and this is khan's model
is that reason doesn't serve desire
reason is doesn't aim to
make the satisfact to efficiently
achieve the satisfaction of desire but
reason does its own thing entirely
so in other words
as kant would have it uh the goal of
reason is not to serve desire but to
make sure that
rational beings are respected
as rational beings
so i would recast
that question that way
okay
well
that brings us to a close of another dr
sadler's philosophy form i'd like to
thank my guest morris stern
for some and i'm going to make a pun
here some very enlightening uh
discussion about kant
i'd like to remind anybody who uh missed
it at the start that morris is actually
going to be doing some more talking
about kant on the punk rock philosopher
show
um which is a spreaker
uh radio show if you if you want to find
it just type in punk rock philosopher to
google and it'll come up right away he's
going to be
doing some some of that on the 26th of
april
at 11 o'clock central time 12 o'clock uh
eastern time and also on may 3rd
um
anything else that we should uh hit on
before we sign off
nothing comes to my mind
okay well i'd like to thank you for for
coming on the show has been a lot of fun
all right so we'll call that a wrap
wrap it up
you